you were working at the discovery
channel oh no yeah we kind of both
stopped we put it away but we had other
things that we were we kind of worried I
still ambitious i got i learned i was at
Discovery Channel so I got to learn
about just programming and the realities
of television programming and
programming for a network I mean no you
know it wasn't fun and games like it was
in community television when could do
anything you wanted just what heavy
metal parking lot came out of I mean
there was a lot more at stake and a lot
more that when you know a lot of all
sorts of factors to pleasing advertise
advertisers marketing you know just
broadcast standards or cablecast
standards what have you it's just a lot
that you know I learned over the
five-year period and during that time is
when I had ambitions to still be
providing being a filmmaker and being a
documentary maker and being interested
in creating content for television I
mean I really have always been a fan of
television and I wanted to that's when
we had the idea to do the Ernest
Borgnine on tour it was called Ernest
Borgnine on tour was going to be a TV
show about Ernest Borgnine driving a bus
it was like a proto reality show because
it was reality the concept was a reality
series TV series kind of like a rock and
roll band on the road but it's Ernest
Borgnine the Hollywood actor driving his
bus because he did he drove a bus it was
this crazy concept that my colleague
somebody I worked with a discovery
channel Brendan Conway he and i just
used to kind of crack each other up with
ideas for our own TV the TV shows in our
heads and this was one of them heard us
Borgnine driving his bus because of a
bit mixture of like Charles Kuralt the
the on the Sunday morning on the road
what was the show called think something
like that yeah it was that Charles
Kuralt you know part by any biography
and
you know just partridge family I don't
know anything all the whole mixture but
Hollywood Hollywood meeting every man
and and if Ernest Borgnine does
Hollywood legend if he didn't drive the
bus if he was being driven wouldn't have
worked but this man drove his own
40-foot bus this it's like an RV only
it's a souped-up bus and he drove it and
we thought that was the funniest thing
and the coolest thing and that was how
we decided we wanted to pitch and
develop a TV series that was um you know
part biography part you know on the road
meeting civilians and history and just
kind of seeing America and so that's was
how we created this I think Brendan knew
that he from reading somewhere in the
National Enquirer that he had a Buster
there was a news story or he was on
Regis and Kathie Lee or something that
talking about it but that's how it all
started we ended up pitching the agent
kind of saying we were from Discovery
Channel even though we weren't
authorized from Discovery but we both
worked there so we weren't lying it was
true it just it we were basically that
helped us get in to be taken seriously
and then in fact when we had the
opportunity we had to go ahead and get
footage for a real because nobody
understood we were talking about it
didn't make sense reality TV it was five
years before reality TV even became a
term you know in 1999 with the osbournes
on mtv so we realized we had to get it
off the page because we did try to pitch
it so we went out to Milwaukee and
basically followed him with his son in
this bus for five days and got enough
footage for a real that we then created
a real and tried to sell that and when
that didn't sell we had enough in the
can for a documentary and that's how we
have Ernest Borgnine on the bus a
documentary that is him driving his bus
and doing exactly what we wanted to do
with four in a 50 minute documentary
so during that time then heavy metal
parking lot has got this this life of
its own with it within these musicians
and this you know video store here and
i'll write and so unbeknownst to you
you're making this project you're on the
road well no we had known about because
we got wind of the heavy metal heavy
metal parking lot became back in our got
back in or our frame of reference you
know i got out of mothballs and we
started thinking about it as a current
title or something that we had to work
with rather that we needed to start
exploiting at the same time i was doing
i had doing it was doing the ernest
borgnine project okay and so that helped
also get me the piss by this point
people know about heavy metal parking
lot so or certain people in the
entertainment world and that just was a
good entree to be able to use that and
then i'll say oh but i also have this
ernest borgnine idea and he had been he
was being rediscovered we kind of lost
our app or window with him because he
went on was the he started a TV show on
NBC called the single guy with jonathan
silverman you know NBC you know
primetime show so he wasn't available to
go Ryan and running around the country
anymore on the bus which he did for
months at a time and so that's when we
were trying to pitch the show because we
didn't want to make a TV series but we
adapted we changed it for because we had
enough stuff and they can just to get a
documentary and he was great he was
always very supportive harness Borgnine
he thought it was a hoot and we were
very very grateful for that and how long
were you on the road with him a week
okay that's just it we were only there
for not even the fifth day we don't get
back to Nebraska you know get back from
Nebraska to Wisconsin to fly because the
hope fly back home when I was paying a
crew rate so I had I couldn't afford
anymore the whole idea was just to get
some something in the can to sell the
idea
and and that's why we could only afford
the four or five days to do this but it
was to get like nobody knew what we were
talking about and we needed to show the
bus and show Ernie driving the bus and
show the the father-son dynamic and show
us you know trying to chase after them
and get him talking about his career and
all of his movies and showbiz anecdotes
which people love I love and so the the
point I so I just said let's just tape
everything and and that's how we got the
real five-minute real and that's what we
then tried to sell the series with and
we couldn't but we instead sold the idea
of a documentary which was great because
I always knew that was a I always knew
it was possibly going to be you know
just a very expensive home movie
starring Ernest Borgnine if nothing else
but luckily we were able to get it on as
a home video release on a label called
them good times good times home video
like you could have bought it they it
was at a catalog so they put it out and
now it's you know it never made it to
DVD but it did go on on VHS now it's on
the web
you